hardcore Henry is in theaters right now
and it's a first-person film entirely
from the point of view of somebody who's
been cybernetically augmented this guy
wakes up in some medical office we are
looking through his eyes he was told
that he was in an accident and he can
see all of his limbs being reattached
his wife is right there reattaching his
limbs he's told that he has all these
superhuman abilities now he can kick a
ton of ass and this evil corporation
called akin is the one that put him in
this position and so he goes out to
destroy every single one of these people
this movie came about because a guy made
a short film called bad motherfucker on
YouTube and that short film was all from
the first-person perspective it was very
successful and now we have a 90 minute
film from this point of view and I got
to tell you it's very impressive what
they're able to do the stunt work in
this film blew my mind and that's by far
the most impressive aspect of hardcore
Henry at least for me the stunt work and
the things they were able to accomplish
with this technique is really
mind-blowing and I got to give them
major credit for pulling it off and
making it mostly very convincing my
favorite part of this movie by far is
Sholto copeley this guy is incredible he
gets to play a very versatile character
he has tons of interesting things to do
and say he also gives the film the
majority of its humor but unfortunately
that technique that is very impressive
for about 30 minutes loses its impact
after a while and you start to care less
about what's going on in fact you don't
really care at all because the
characterization in this film is very
poor shelter Copley's character is the
most entertaining and fun part of this
movie but he basically exists to be the
guide to tell Henry where to go after he
kills like a thousand people there'll be
this crazy frenetic action scene with
all this insane stuff happening and then
it'll end and he'll look at his phone
and Sharlto will have like a dot on a
GPS saying hey go here this is where
more people are you got to kill and
that's basically the movie it really is
like a cinematic video game and if that
sounds cool to you then you'll probably
love it if you love FPSs you'll probably
love it too but it does get tiresome
after a while because the film doesn't
really have anything to do beyond
blowing up hundreds of people from the
first-person perspective and after a
while the film doesn't really have
anywhere to go there's also some very
lazy sound effects work in this movie
there's one scene that has the exact
same tire screeching sound effect four
times in a row and the
course of like 30 seconds still the
technique is impressive and I give the
filmmakers major merit for being able to
pull this off and making it look
realistic but after a while it's just
there isn't really any meat to this
movie it's like a bone skeleton and
there's just there's not enough meat to
be added to this story to make me
actually care about this stuff that's
happening and there's also a poor sense
of elevation that it doesn't really feel
like the film builds to an amazing
climax it just feels like it's 90
minutes of go go go go go go go go go go
go go go and after a while it's just
like okay let's just let's take a
breather here for a minute and do
something else but that never happens
I'm gonna give hardcore Henry a C+ I
think if you're an action junkie like I
am it is worth seeing at least once just
to experience it but I don't really
think it's we're seeing in theaters guys
if you miss my review of the Star Wars
rogue one trailer which looks amazing I
explained why I have braces in that
video so I'm not going to go into detail
about it ever again if you guys want to
know why I have braces that's the video
to watch thank you so much as always for
watching guys you're the best if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes